he's a big human being he's so big size
strength coordination IQ
the goal for him is to get drafted I
can't wait to go out there and show the
world that I'm ready for them do it
the rents 10 feet in the air and sim has
over a nine foot standing reach I've
been told the whole life to me is
adorable he's seven three and a half
barefoot which puts him right about
seven foot five which is what we list am
at seven feet five inches I miss out
here getting ready for the draft working
on my game getting a shape sim is really
a one-of-a-kind player and he's the
biggest player I've I've ever trained
I focus on that job there it is good
babe okay beautiful way to read them
ultimate goal is definitely the beat I
guess be one of the pioneers Indian
basketball hopefully lead the way for a
lot of a lot of young Indians growing up
and in my career I definitely want to
look back and know that I've made an
impact in their be and hopefully
basketball around the world
he's a phenomenal human being great kid
comes from a really really good family I
came in gander December 1989 for better
life better school better health care
system and safer living my definite foci
representing the account equal yummy I'm
from Canada but I still feel like I'm
both near grew up in India household my
parents came over from India not too
long ago he was more than 11 pounds and
he was born we Lilly is going to be a
big boy and he was always taller than
his classmate and his age group case my
dad's is about 6-3 6-4 alums 511 60 when
he was young he loved to eat just
ketchup and bread if I ask him same
candy cookies on top no mom just ketchup
and bread
I'd be a teamster dropping because I'm a
big guy and clogged up a ik and I can
protect the rim I can rebound the ball I
think I'm ready right now I can go under
I play right away and I think I can
change the game in a big way I think
obviously a team that's committed to
playing big men the NBA obviously has
teams to play up and down and fast and
teams and maybe slow it down in you on
the size we've been working on his
conditioning you know there's only 24
second shot clock in the NBA and he's
gonna have to get up and down and the
way the game is being played nowadays is
it's very spread out I lost about 17
pounds since I've been here and just
just a month I feel myself more
comfortable on my body and moving around
a lot easier and I can definitely knock
down the memories jump shot now
consistently high when you're seven five
like he is getting from spot to spot and
being a mobile athlete is so much more
difficulties you know he's got
phenomenal basketball IQ never had any
issues with him offensively or
defensively for getting plays or missing
assignments and things like that he's
he's a really smart kid and a really
smart basketball he's gonna give you an
honest day's work he's gonna be a really
fun guy to be around and he's gonna do
everything that you ask him to do if
SCIM become the first Indian player it
will be best moment for us and it mean
us a lot it mean God get worse son who
is one of in billions if I don't get
drafted hopefully I get picked up by a
team and go out to some really improve
myself I mean I know I got a long way to
go but I think I'm ready
what are you hoping to show the skills
in there today I just show Mom the shape
I'm I woke up to go up and out of the
corner bank with other babes and knock
down shots how did it feel working out
in front of a team than you do idolizing
in Washington to be able to work out for
them is just a blessing I mean as a kid
this is a dream that you want to happen
and it's a good thing that I'm right
here do you see any parallels between
you and yelling what he did for one turn
yeah I mean I think I could do that to
the backbone India I mean I really want
to be a role model for the kids and open
their eyes know they can do anything it
was admire to give it an opportunity to
think I could make things happen this
team at the end of the day being able to
see my name on a back of the NBA jersey
that could be reality